two years of pandemic lockdowns and now
soaring prices
Paul De Balthazar says he used to be
able to provide enough for his family
before the pandemic he made daily trips
as a driver but restrictions now limit
him to three or four Journeys a week
I only make six or seven dollars a day
that's weird enough for food life has
become really difficult
holding at the budget of less than six
dollars on the day we accompanied him to
the neighborhood market
a quarter of the money was spent on Rice
another quarter on chicken the rest on a
bunch of bananas some vegetables and few
pieces of sausages and fish
he said it was food for two days for his
family of six
developed Nation prices in a developing
economy this is how many Filipinos
describe the increasing costs of basic
commodities
one of the most significant a cooking
staple onions at around ten dollars a
kilogram they're among some of the most
expensive onions in the world
there was no way Paul D could afford
onions but even middle-class Filipinos
are hurting
well the economy is growing inflation in
December was the highest in almost a
decade and a half even though oil prices
have started declining that does not
mean prices are going to go down that
just means prices won't go up as fast as
before and that's going to be a problem
if families are not going to be earning
enough not only for the business and
while President Ferdinand Marcus Jr has
been touting economic recovery he's also
acknowledged the high costs of basic
Goods our unemployment rate is
quite reasonable considering the
situation however on the other side of
that coin there is still inflation that
is running rampant and out of control
Paulie says he has no choice but to make
do but he hates seeing his children
suffering he hopes that whatever gains
the economy makes in the near future
trickle down to ordinary Filipinos
find it below Al Jazeera Manila